if you thought Danny versus Laurel was
mind blowing you ain't seen or should I
say you ain't heard nothing yet because
this auditory illusion that popped up in
the wake of Yanni vs. Laurel is so much
better
unlike Laurel most people can actually
switch between what they're hearing with
this one in fact the effect here is so
strong you'll never be able to trust
your own senses again so even if you
have heard of this one before stick
around because to analyze the truth of
what's going on in this one we're gonna
be unwrapping a whole slew of other
illusions that prove just how lazy and
easy to manipulate our brains actually
are first just listen don't go down in
the comments yet what did you just hear
if did you hear this word or did you
hear this now try switching between them
by focusing on one word at a time if
everything's going according to plan you
should be able to switch between them
based on which word you have currently
in your vision and now here's the
original video which as you watch it
should actually strengthen your
perception of green needle but here's
the kicker what's actually being said
here is brainstorm
that's the character's name from the
show Ben 10 where this toy originates
but how all this works is gonna blow
your mind um blow your ears wait no no
that just sounds painful anyway
hello Internet welcome to the show
that's entirely justified in covering
this topic today since I sometimes cover
the science psychology and lore of
YouTube videos so by this point I'm sure
we're all familiar and totally sick of
the yeah Neil oral debate rights Laurel
last steps I saw 47% of people were able
to hear Yanni and 53% were able to hear
Laurel let me give you another shot here
Laurel honestly for the life of me I can
only hear Laurel until of course you
start pitch shifting it and honestly
that's my big problem with this auditory
illusion most people are stuck only
hearing one of the two
have a really hard time hearing the
other one without some kind of big
change whereas most people are able to
switch between the brainstorm green
needle audio pretty darn easily in fact
I can even control it for you here's the
best part
unlike the Annie Laurel where the final
explanation about what was really going
on was quite honestly kinda boring
talking about higher and lower
frequencies being overlaid and different
sound qualities coming out of different
speakers blah blah blah yawn the reasons
behind why we experienced the brainstorm
Green Needle auditory illusion actually
reveal a lot about how our brains
function how lazy they are and how
unreliable our senses can be so get
ready to start distrusting yourself
because here we go to begin scientists
would classify the brainstorm green
needle illusion as an example of what's
known as bi-stable perception where a
stimulus is just too ambiguous for human
senses to process with only one
interpretation these are the sorts of
illusions that allow you to switch
between how you're seeing them in the
case of our Ben Tenn friend it's how
you're able to hear breathe on one
playthrough and just as well on a second
playthrough but auditory illusions like
this are incredibly rare most bi-stable
stimuli are visual like the Schroeder
staircase where you can either see the
staircase going up into the laughs or
you can see an upside-down staircase
going down into the right there's the
all-time classic faces versus bases or
you can always go with the Internet's
favorite that were league early where as
you watch you can actually see her
spinning in one direction and then all
of a sudden out of the blue she'll just
switch directions scientific surveys
have shown that most people start seeing
a rotating clockwise a 6535 split but I
swear I swear I never could see her goin
anything but counterclockwise until
actually working on this episode then I
just use the arrow keys to have YouTube
jump forwards
backwards by five seconds to break the
flow of the image briefly suddenly I was
able to see it moving in both ways
it is crazy so if you're like me and
having trouble seeing it rotating in the
opposite direction try that I'll give
you a few seconds to buffer well I
deliver you a musical interlude oh and
by the way don't believe online articles
that say which direction you see are
spinning determines your dominant brain
hemisphere or it's an indicator of how
smart you are
science is actually debunked all of that
what are the other interesting wrinkles
of brainstorm green needle is that it's
a cross-modal problem which means that
it involves multiple different senses
hearing and sight Danny vs. Laurel is
just auditory you see our brains are
constantly piecing together bits of
information from all of our senses to
form solid ideas of objects and events
in the world around us usually these
pieces of information complement and
confirm each other
thereby improving the reliability of our
perception but when things don't match
up in the way that the brain expects
that's gonna get some weird results
there's one of my all-time favorites the
motion bounce illusion watch these two
balls pass through each other
nothing super remarkable right now watch
it again
did the balls pass through each other
again or did they bounce off of each
other
watch him bounce again it's the exact
same thing I showed you the first time
but your brain perceives the balls
bouncing off each other because the
sound triggers it to think that there
was some sort of collision happening
it's using past experience of balls
coming together a couple moves a sound
that it's hearing to inform what you're
seeing and it's telling you that you
should be seeing a collision and your
perception adjusts accordingly the same
is true for this next illusion how many
times you see Deadpool's face appear on
screen twice right let's try it again
twice again now let's slow it way down
while keeping the sound in you see that
it only happens once this phenomenon is
called the sound induced flash illusion
where the sound was influencing what you
were seeing happening on screen so again
we get an example of a cross-modal
illusion where our sense of hearing is
affecting our perception of sight and
it's not just limited to those two
senses both hearing and sight can affect
touch too
take for instance the marble hand
illusion which is pretty darn wild
scientists hit participants hands with a
small hammer while playing noise the
noise starts off as just the sound of a
hammer hitting skin but it slowly
transitions to the sound of a hammer
hitting marble and get this across the
board the test subjects were pouring in
their hand feeling heavier stiffer and
harder but if you think that was crazy
on its own get this the tests also
showed their skin conductance or the
electrical conductivity of their skin
also went down just like you would see
out of an object made of stone crazy now
admittedly it's a bit difficult to smack
your hand with a hammer over the
Internet
so instead let's try something else put
on headphones and start rubbing your
hands together like this in three two
one felt pretty normal right all right
let's try it again in three two one
your hands should have felt moister that
time did they
now stop rubbing those gross moist hands
of yours and let's try one more time in
3 2 1
there that should have helped dry them
off for you this phenomenon is called
the parchment hand Elysian where sound
is directly influencing your sense of
touch you are basically feeling the
feelings that the sounds are telling you
to feel feels pretty good and wet and
moist and sticky which is just kind of
weird sure all this is fun and games but
how do all these cross-modal illusions
apply to brainstorm and green needle
well look at the original video notice
how the podium flashes three times even
though the toy is officially saying
brainstorm the word brainstorm is only
two syllables but we're seeing three
flashes from the toy which seems like
they should coincide with the syllables
that we're hearing our brain is looking
to hear a three syllable phrase that'll
match up with the cadence of those
flashes and the phrase that best matches
is green needle or other things that are
kind of close but obviously that can't
be the whole story here because as I
demonstrated at the top of the episode
you are able to hear both brainstorm and
green needle without me ever showing you
a video clip all it took was hearing the
audio and seeing the words and this is
perhaps the biggest differentiator with
yani versus Laurel because no amount of
me showing you Yanni on screen while
playing the audio is gonna get you to
hear it if you can't already well it
turns out that one of the major reasons
we hear and are able to switch between
the words brainstorm and green needle is
because of the psychological process of
priming where your brain gets
preconditioned into one thought pattern
and thus tries to fit new stimuli into
the pattern moving forward for instance
let me talk to you about how much I love
showers now that might seem a bit weird
for me to talk about right now but
sometimes I just can't help it I love
talking about and taking showers I love
getting clean I love washing my hair I
like singing and thinking in the shower
I love
I love the shower I also got a
confession I love washing my hands in
the sink I use Old Spice and water or
dove and water mostly but sometimes I've
been feeling particularly wild and
slippery I'm not opposed to the
occasional Irish spring and water but
enough about my bathing and hygiene
habits if I were to ask you to complete
this word that you see on screen right
now what would you say most people at
this point should say soap thanks to the
effect of priming specifically
associative priming I got you thinking
in the pattern of bathrooms and washing
which makes you much more likely to see
those letters and think so rather than
things like step stop C for any of the
other words that fit that pattern think
about associative priming like a web
with each word as its own node in that
web I activated all of the words around
soap without actually saying soap itself
so when presented with the opportunity
to fill in that word your brain jumped
at the chance but priming can also have
some unexpected consequences too for
instance stereotypes are actually a form
of psychological priming one of the most
extreme examples to show this came from
a study by ship tin ski and embody where
they took Asian American women and gave
them a math test
sucks to be subjects in that study now
the generally believed stereotype for
those who have Asian descent is that
they're great at math and conversely the
stereotype for women is that they're
worse in math than men hey don't shoot
the messenger I'm not the one who said
it it's society okay take it up with
society you probably already have on
Twitter somewhere anyway in the test one
group was primed to focus on their Asian
identity and the other was primed to
focus on their female identity and get
this the group who is primed with the
positive stereotype outperformed the
control group while the one who was
primed with the negative stereotype
performed worse now when it comes to
brainstorm versus green needle when you
choose to focus on one of the two words
on screen to try and switch what you're
hearing that's direct priming in action
you're using visual stimuli to trigger
your brain into thinking along a certain
pattern and what you hear is affected
accordingly honestly if I were to say
brain need
and then show you the words brain needle
and then play the clip for you there's
probably a pretty strong likelihood that
you just heard brain needle and that
isn't even one of our options
it's priming in its prime you've been
primed in a way that the yeah Neil oral
auditory illusion could never do so in
short I hope today's episode proved two
things for you first that your senses
are actually completely unreliable we
can't count on our brains to tell us
anything accurately I mean think about
it every second your brain is trying to
make sense of all your sensory inputs to
create a mental map of the world around
you the processing power this takes is
immense estimated to be up to the
equivalent of a hundred million MIPS
that's a hundred million million
instructions per second if your brain
were built like a standard computer so
your brain comes up with all sorts of
shortcuts to help you quickly sort and
categorize things and patterns tactics
like priming means that we don't have to
consciously look at every item in a room
and rack our brains for a definition we
just instantly know that a chair is a
chair is a chair despite all three of
those things looking fairly different
from each other and secondly look on the
upside the next time one of these
controversial mystery videos hits
YouTube and the rest of social media
heart you'll know the secrets behind why
everyone's losing their collective
online shorts and you'll be able to be
the person to set the record straight
instead of shaming people because
they're too old to hear the right word
we're going on a rage-fueled bender in
the comments section you'll be able to
tackle the next magic video craze armed
with the knowledge that all of our
brains have a little bit of faulty
wiring and that using just a little bit
of science we can trick them into seeing
and hearing and feeling all sorts of
crazy and explicable things except
they're totally splittable we just split
them remember that our brains are doing
a lot of work all the time so they're
always looking for ways to be lazier and
work more efficiently now you're armed
with the knowledge that the illusions we
cover today are all examples of what
happens when things slip through the
cracks unfortunately after watching this
episode you've also realized that you've
been primed to click on the subscribe
button as soon as I say but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and actually for being a hundred percent
honest it's more likely that you've been
primed to just click to another video
when I say those words but hey a click
on the subscribe button would be really
nice and really appreciated and cuts
[Music]